[موسيقى]
هناك عدد قليل جدًا من الأماكن في العالم التي
أجد فيها أينما نظرت
تذهب ، آه أوه ، إنها مجرد صورة
بطاقة بريدية رائعة.
لمحة عن البندقية
تتجاوز ما هو واضح وهو كيف
انتهى بي المطاف هنا
أوسكار ولورنزو رباني أخت
وشقيق يديران متجرًا كان
في العائلة منذ ما يقرب من 70 عامًا ثلاثة
أجيال ،
نحن الجيل الثالث الذي
تصممه هنا في البندقية
مع
المفهوم الفينيسي وراء
ما هو هذا
المفهوم ، المفهوم
هو جمال
مدينتنا ، اللون الذي في الضباب
في الشتاء
عندما تكون البندقية هادئة ، هناك شغف حقيقي
عندما تتحدث عن البندقية ، هناك
شغف حقيقي ليس نعم نعم
مع خلفية  في الفن والحب الخالص
لتصميمات مدينتها ، فإن تصميمات فوسكا فريدة من
نوعها الشكل
الذي تختاره لتصميم
كيف يقول هذا
فينيس ريح العمارة
القوطية المعمارية أو
العمارة الرومانسية لدي  نظارات مزخرفة
منذ الطفولة ومرّت بكل
تكرار يمكنك التفكير فيه ،
ولكن
التصميم جميل دعنا
نكرر شكل الجندول
[الموسيقى]
هذا اللون الذي أطلقنا عليه اسم prosecco في الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي
.
خلاف حول المكان
ولكن اسأل أحد خبراء البندقية وسيقولون إنه
كان صانع زجاج في جزيرة
مورانو
[موسيقى]
حرفيو زجاج بورانو معروفون في جميع
أنحاء العالم
، وجدت فوسكا طريقة لدمج
هذا الفن الفينيسي في
تصميماتها إذا كان عليك ذلك  وصف
البندقية ، الحمض النووي ،
إنها سيدة عجوز ،
لكن الموضة
اليوم أيضًا ،
لا نعم ،
إنها سيدة صغيرة
ترتدي فستانًا جميلًا
ولكن
مع الأحذية منحنية بعض الشيء
[موسيقى]
سيدة أرستقراطية عجوز ولدت في تلك
الأيام المليئة بالمسكرة في جمهورية البندقية
بداخلها  من تلك القصور القديمة العظيمة
وإلقاء نظرة خاطفة على ما قد تكون عليه تلك الحياة
كما لو
عدنا مع ستيفانو نيكول الذي
التقيته سابقًا في الزيارة ،
أنا أستعد للسير على المدرج  في عرض الأزياء الخاص به
، ليس لدي أي فكرة عما
أفعله ، ما الذي أفعله ، نعم ، نعم ، نعم ،
لكنني أعلم أنني لا أريد أن أفشل
الأمر ، وهم جميعًا يعرفون ما
يفعلونه جيدًا
، فهذه قبعة
واحدة تلو الأخرى.  مرتديًا عندما
أسير في جولة ، نعم ، هل تريد
شخصية أو تريد نموذج الحقيبة لا
لا لا لا توجد
رؤية ستيفانو واضحة قصة
البندقية من خلال عقود من التصميمات
التي ابتكرها لأفلام ومنتجات شهيرة ،
بدأت تمامًا في رؤيتها هذه
غرفة رائعة ، عظمة
تاريخ
الأمراء والقصور
[موسيقى
] والآن
دوري
بمجرد وصولي إلى هناك كل شخص
في الواقع ومن ثم
فإن الحبيب يبدو
وكأنه يبدو خناجر توسكا الجريح في وجهي
والشر وأنا أحاول
حسنًا ، الجمهور نوعًا
ما يستمتع تمامًا بكل شيء
كان جيدًا حقًا حقًا ، لقد
حصلت عليها في النهاية ،
لكنها بعد ذلك تقتلني
البندقية ، المكان الذي عانى أكثر
من ألف عام من التاريخ يتسرب
من كل قناة كل حجر كل
أعتقد أن كلمة القصر هي الكلمة المثالية التي
تصف كل هذا وستريد أن
تأتي وتتمتع البندقية
بنفسك
ولا شك أنها جزء من
عالمنا المليء بالعجائب.